welcome to another episode of the
award-winning podcast not too deep I'm
your host grace Helbig this is a very
exciting episode we have a repeat guess
it is now the independent content
creator Lily Marsden you might know her
from clever TV from Beauty break from
just you know a cog in the system over
to fie media I have been through the
situation that has been happening over
there it's very controversial it's very
interesting it's goofy it's silly and
you know what she's come out on the
other side and I was so excited to talk
to her about it you'll really like this
episode also I learned a horrendous tip
about SpaghettiOs so please watch with
caution enjoy this episode of not too
deep with Lily Marcin this episode of
not too deep is brought to you by our
good buddies at Squarespace turn your
great idea into a reality with
Squarespace
Squarespace makes it easier than ever to
launch your passion project whether
you're showcasing your work or selling
products of any kind with beautiful
templates and the ability to customize
just about anything you can easily make
a beautiful website yourself and if you
do get stuck Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support is there
to help
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain Lily Marston its back with us
on another episode of not too deep and
this time very different circumstances I
feel like I've watched this you know you
came on here and then you went into a
cocoon and now you're a butterfly coming
back to not too deep no a butterfly baby
like a dead moth I'm so excited to talk
to you because you can finally kind of
talk without constraints I know does
that feel weird and it does like I still
feel like I've liked it but I'll have to
say that it's like nothing's like else I
mean nothing's like bad but like well
the thing is I think it's just a very
different perspective when you're in
mm-hmm
a situation like that then like the
viewers see like they think we all just
like happy a hundred percent and I've
been through something so similar with a
company called My Damn Channel which is
the place that I actually met
Fairey director producer extraordinaire
of the net judy podcast and we had a
similar situation with this company and
that was like really taking advantage of
a lot of the talent and then wasn't
negotiating and then all of a sudden
like [ __ ] it's like literally back I
mean that's not how we met because we
met a bit Cod when I was like wasted to
be just like oh my god like you dyed
your hair so watching Megan ranks a
story I know who you are but watch I've
been like in love with little weirdo in
the background it's like editing all of
her videos No then I reach out because I
knew you had gone through the same
scenario and we got drinks like it was
probably like two years ago yeah we got
drinks and this is you go back into the
DM it's like me being like
hypothetically could I ask you could I
like pick your brain on just totally for
no reason just I just I would have no
reasoning for this information but I
just I was like corporation taking
advantage of you yeah okay I have some
insight into this for sure as a
contactor five hours getting so drunk oh
we got so drunk at Barney's Beanery and
this is like I drove my car there
thinking like we're just gonna have like
a business drink and then like cut to
five hours later being like I'll come
back to my car hey if I get a ticket I
got a ticket it's fine
and I think the funny thing too is the
Barney's Beanery was in West Hollywood
it's like the straightest bar in like
the gayest neighborhood in LA all of
these frat boys think that we're on I
can't rap because it was loud and we
were like having like very serious
conversations and it started like oh
like clever by Dave channel but it was
like so when I was 10 right now we're
friends we were like leaning in on the
goop that was kind of like you're
sitting further away than like to have
like a really intimate conversation
where a guy comes up he goes like wow
you guys seem really close weird comment
like where did you guys meet and then
even clearly like coming up to hit on us
and both of us just look at him like
cats they were like are you interrupting
me like you'd seem to like really know
each other really well and we're like
you could hear our eye rolls of being
like we don't want any of them it was
really fun cut to two years later here
we are
here you are for those cheers hey it's a
Thursday in LA and it's raining so like
I need an excuse okay so for people that
don't know how do you summarize the
situation that's happening right now I
know you've talked about it like ad
nauseam with a lot of people
so basically me uninvolved from the
situation what happened was defy is the
parent company that owned clever and
Smosh and used to own screen junkies on
me so is it media company owned like
several different very successful
properties right so when I first started
working at clever alloy digital owned in
and that was the parent company but then
I think it was only like a year two went
by before then alloy digital merged with
break calm okay it was like now looking
back hmm it's like this kind of like
rhonchi like bikini like even more yeah
like I had our ads were running on they
were like testing okay overlay ads on
website it's one time and I got a text
from a guy that I went to college with
and he was don't judge me for like this
is what I was looking up but it's a
screen shot and it's like 10 best
brothels in Thailand and it's just my
face playing over iiving out here no
thanks he was like is there something
you need to tell me
we'd go watch the videos I'm actually
and it's like yeah yeah putting glitter
all over our hair so long story short
the parent company despite all of the
channels doing well like I think clever
style and Smosh specifically and clever
news we're all like making money no you
guys were from what I estimated like you
guys were on the upward trajectory one
like for a while I feel like we had kind
of plateaued and like the views
definitely weren't like they weren't how
they were like a few years ago when
Beauty break first blow-up where it's
like oh it's like half straight and
Johnson's
hair that's a little bit par for the
course of the YouTube plugs are men in
general oh and everything yeah so things
I thought like kind of maybe like
started not doing that great so it
wasn't like we were getting like Pat's
on the back every single day oh my god
you're getting such great views but also
the monetization has changed and one
thing that I think is very crucial to
mention is we never had acts I didn't
see what the videos were making so it's
like like it has to me what yeah could
be making but the CPM is per video
totally changed that's the craziest
thing because when I was doing Daily
Grace from item channel I could see the
back I don't know which was reports I
don't know either both are so soul
crushing but at least I was like just
blissfully ignorant and when I say
blissfully like not at all but it was
and this was like before brand deals
were a big thing before like see PM's
were a different you know ratio and I
was saying that they were making like
five six seven times more than they were
paying me and I was just like defeat it
I think I even knew like because back in
the day it was pretty much like for a
million views you go to thousand dollars
right and so for the for the amount of
content that was being produced II it
was yeah I didn't fully make sense to
make because I never bothered myself
with learning about the financial end
because I didn't have to because I've
know he's so pissed
yeah but also I think things have become
so public in the way that we are there
weren't articles that you could google
and like look do reasons right so even
now more than ever you can kind of
guesstimate how much money a youtuber or
company is getting based on the number
of views that they're getting and the
number of ad placements that they're
having etc etc etc we also
I don't even know where like there's
some more angles so story but basically
the company parent company ran out of
money from poor business decisions that
were like unrelated to the YouTube
channels I also don't think that all
production costs and everything were
managed totally in the smartest way but
like it's our shirts definitely we're
taking up the money that bankrupt the
company you know you guys like
everything they'd be like oh what do you
want from like it would be like
something like salad place namely go
that's fine I'll buy my own lunch
like that's how sites literally people
like wouldn't even get lunch on branded
shoots um yes so to find out that they I
think I've heard different numbers but
I've heard like 10 million over 30
million and then they were stealing it
from the network partners to is
ridiculous I had been negotiating a
contract to be part of the network when
they hadn't paid people in a couple
months I'm like so why were you yeah
yeah it's all shady business deals it's
all very confusing and it's just weird
to me because when this happened you
know what the company Jack and I worked
for it was that's six years ago so you
would think that this sort of thing
would be like figure yeah and I'm not
super surprised even when everyone's
like it kind of almost because in my
video was like what happened in five but
it was also like why I left because I
left before it that's the crazy body
trying to do it for yes a long time
since the two years ago that we first
got drinks you had already like had a
seed planted that nature we had even
gotten drinks that original time I had I
did renew my contract and I know in
Shane's video he talks about like
telling me how much clever start was
making them right what are you talking
about
yeah contracts coming up and I know he
was like very disappointed in me that I
did sign it but I had mentioned I had
been making any money before so I didn't
have any savings so it's not like I and
it's not like you start a YouTube
channel and instantly that month you're
like suddenly getting all these checks
it's like even if you were getting a
bunch of deals and doing well you're not
gonna see the money for a couple months
at least right I'm like who's paying my
rent in the meantime because I'm living
paycheck to paycheck
ya know that's the thing that people
don't see which i think is so
fascinating right now cuz you as it's so
hard to explain to an audience right now
the financials of youtube nor do you
really want to explain the financials of
youtube but there's been some
salacious articles and some like
conversations about youtubers make
millions of dollars whenever they'd like
post anything and it may be that there's
a website that has my net worth listed
at 11.5 million thank you not even what
what are they basing this on I don't
know if that was maybe like taking like
all the clever channels and like when
you're like the president and clever I
guess I don't know it's very confusing
that's insane yeah there's a lot of for
lack of a better word not fake news but
like false information out there about
leg youtubers and the the financial
situations that everyone is in womans
there's no secret that you can make
money but it's like also not just like
you suddenly sign up for YouTube channel
and you a million dollars there's no
guarantees right I think the scariest
thing and I'm curious to hear your
thoughts on it from me when I left Daily
Grace and I started my own channel I was
really terrified but I had no other
choice like I really had no other choice
and I was like trying to do other things
at the same time so I felt like I had
some other stuff going on if starting a
new YouTube channel was a complete flop
because I had no idea I know anyway like
the same thing I've said well yeah and
so I'm curious if you like to hear how
you felt like going through that because
one you are Lilly you're not clever so
they can't know they and that's what
some people like people you know
pep-talk me about when I was going
through it they're like you're they have
Daily Grace sure but they don't grace
Helbig like you are your own personality
like the audience that is signed up to
watch your videos watch for you not for
this company and so I'm sure there was a
ton of like dread and anxiety around
like breaking off and like how does that
work for you so it was hard because also
I wasn't ago shooting my contract so I
was planning on they had agreed that
they were gonna give me ownership of my
channel back so I knew I would be
starting with at least a gym start it
had like 260 thousand subscribers yeah
and I launched it when Shane helped me
like to you two and a half years a hell
chivalrous of them to allow you your
channel exactly so and I and I've gone
in when I told them I was leaving and I
was like look I don't think that we're
ever going to negotiate a contract
full-time exclude
Sibley that I'm gonna be happy with yeah
I don't want to waste my money on a
lawyer to be honest yeah and I have been
wanting to do my channel like I've
literally been begging them for it it's
like had several conversations that
always really Kay yeah you'll get it but
it just like never actually went through
the actual process so then I knew I was
getting that back but then the catch was
that I had to join the network which was
exactly what they did I had no idea that
defi was an MCN as well I yeah Lisa
Schwartz and Ryland and all these people
like with them I had no idea that the
thing is I didn't even really know that
until randomly it would be like oh this
person in the network and that's like
how we started hanging out with Adalind
oh really
wait how long has she been in this
network why haven't we met her sooner
and like such like that so then but then
there's people in it like Lisa and Matt
Pat that I'm like I didn't even know
that they oh man Pat's in it to stay put
and he used to work for it if I was like
a consultant - Wow
he used to literally come into our
meetings and be like this is what you
should title your clever whoa he's the
nicest human of all time that's so nuts
to me yeah so okay then so you so
graciously they give you your channel
back so then it was that I had to still
join the network and I did have a
manager friend don't be a negotiator on
the manager and I have a lawyer but like
the lawyer is negotiating what you tell
them to negotiate is right I think the
really quick like piece of advice to
anyone that this resonates with or
anyone that's looking to get an
entertainment like one thing that you do
amazingly is that you ask questions to
all your friends I have any sort of like
connection to anything that you might
not know about there's also like no one
else has the answers so right you have
friends that are in the space they've
definitely gone through the same stuff
yeah willing to tell you because you
don't want your friend to get screwed up
no cuz it sucks when you get screwed so
then so you had to put your channel with
their network so then I thought any of
those meeting I was like hey I'm leaving
like yeah I knew this was coming
I've been literally like I've cried
begging for it like a year earlier and
this is so insane because you went from
being behind the camera - like what
Shane said in Rylands video being the
face of this company an accident right
you and Jocelyn and Erin like just kind
of organically became these like
featured creators on the face of beauty
break and clever and the patrol creature
critters makes me laugh because this
year we finally got a funeral for a
clever I'm down to like hold services
yeah yeah that's so bi no it was like I
was always people like what what did you
want to do I don't know I just like
wanted to work in some kind of video and
then I was like somehow I ended up
finding myself making a show that was a
makeup tutorial show they were horrible
I don't know anything about makeup Megan
didn't know anything about makeup it was
a disaster and I was like let's stop
lying to everyone why no one wants the
show
I don't want it the audience doesn't
want you guys don't want it why are you
making me making it but yeah yeah yeah
and then it just like organically blew
up and it's very much we've always said
it's cuz we're all just like actually
friends and the chemistry isn't fake
well then I started editing it which I
won't even say it's like I'm not only I
mean I would like think I'm a good
editor
you're an amazing editor and also people
don't realize I had up my own videos and
it's like a tenth of what you do to edit
beauty break videos because it's what
people don't know there's like three
different cameras in that studio there's
all the mics it is I think that's the
last of my concerns it's more that I
think what people don't realize is that
editing is producing it yeah it's like
what we didn't have was were people that
could edit it and then I watch it I'm
like I don't even know what notes to
give you but like it's not that's not it
right right and I'm like it's easier for
me to just go in and do it rather than
me like cut these two seconds and have
that note like 80 times because they
don't know how to do jump cuts right
right and so you're doing not only are
you being in front of the camera now
you're producing coming up with the
whole
what is this video go ahead and actually
adding it but also I would say the
producing and the editing very much is
just like my sense of humor right which
is very parallel with all of the other
girls that I work with sense of humor so
I think that's like everything just felt
very normal because it was like what we
would actually be joking around about
and also stuff that you guys are going
to watch if you weren't in that video
exactly because that was bio thing I was
like no one wants to watch this why are
we making it yeah I don't we want to why
don't we make something that people do
want that is me know I don't want to
stab my eyes out for making yeah just
stab your eyes out with whatever like
watching Megan do like this is how you
get Lourdes makeup first of all does
anyone want Lourdes Inca as Lord where
makeup I just have a very dark bold lip
oh okay I guess I missed that oh I mean
yeah so I'm glad that you guys evolved
it do you are you guys working to get
Beauty break back I think I saw that in
like your milk bang with joseline I mean
the thing is is a lot of people like
can't you just deep Beauty break in your
living room can like you could just like
take the table literally Dawson to take
the table to hold on I know like the
office closed or something that video of
her coming back with her car full of her
stuff sack I'm so mad I'm still there I
still need to get back to his anyone
have a truck no so it was like so beauty
break is something like oh but you guys
comes like I beauty break was not
reinventing the wheel literally it's
like I kind of it became this show that
was like kind of the lily and joseline
trying yeah like it's not like we did a
great alternative title that I think you
should take it out we have also
discussed Beauty paws and yeah glamour
recess like what I was saying in the
video at one point like at the end of
the day I'm not I didn't want to say it
like yeah legally I'd be like we're
stealing but Beauty break doesn't even
have a format it's literally us trying
things yeah it's just me editing it so
I'm not editing it in a specific way I'm
just like right putting the footage
together so I think there's not that's
not really a show it's like kind of like
everything
is kind of yeah and we're trying out
beauty products or I always like with
loose like like airplane pillows so you
could get your beauty sleep like oh it's
not very much force again I never wanted
it to be a beauty show I would have
rather it been like a good mythical
morning kind of thing oh that's cool
yeah I can see that but it didn't and
then well there's now there's more than
enough time to make that happen that's I
having one wheel I left Daily Grace it
was like I can't do sexy Friday okay how
about like sensual Thursday what are the
legal terms that I can say and one thing
that was always big with clever and I
think to find in general because like
Smosh too is that they needed shows yeah
you had to have shows interesting at
first it was like the show was just
running indefinitely but then it would
be like well we have to have shows and
seasons and arcs and they have daggers
and it was just something making like
traditional TV do it wasn't and it was
just like no but like can't we just make
this phone or they aren't really fast
yeah like you don't want this right now
and then now more recently before
everything happened it started getting
like all of the trending stuff was like
yeah oh you should hop on this you
should do it like a fun show where we
could just like do kind of anything
right but so I'm not really planning on
making like too many like shows I think
there's a few things that have like a
theme that's consistent enough they're
all like have it be like a recurring
segment a gimmick I don't think you
pigeonholing yourself into like yeah I
have this show every Thursday and I have
to make sure the topic fits yeah I'd
rather just have it be like a
free-for-all I think that's great okay
we're gonna take a quick break when we
get back I have a couple more questions
for you and then we have a billion
Twitter questions so we'll be right back
with the new free independent Lily
Marsden I'm not too deep
jail yeah yeah she's on parole
[Music]
too deep this episode of not too deep is
brought to you by our good buddies at
Squarespace goes wild
they've been sponsoring us for a long
time they've been very supportive so
please go support them because they are
great and also they can help you turn
your dream into a reality would you look
at that they make it easier than ever
for you to launch your passion project
if you're wanting to start a new
business if you want to showcase your
work or publish your content sell
products or more Squarespace is the tool
for you they've got beautiful templates
created by world-class designers and the
ability to customize just about anything
with a few clicks so you can easily make
a beautiful website yourself and they
have powerful ecommerce functionality
that lets you sell anything online and
analytics that help you grow your site
in real time everything is optimized for
mobile right out of the box and there's
nothing to patch or upgrade ever buying
domains is super simple and you'll get
the help you need with Squarespace is
24/7 award-winning customer support
Squarespace empowers millions of people
from designers to lawyers artists to
gamers even restaurants and gyms to turn
great ideas into something real and in
fact I use Squarespace regularly because
I have a lot of Squarespace websites
including the website for this very show
not too deep calm oh wow this is a true
friendship we have a Squarespace and you
can start a friendship with them too by
going to Squarespace calm slash grace
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch use the offer code grace to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain at squarespace.com
slash grace offer code grace squeezing
in time for your family work and hitting
the gym feels impossible something's got
to give and it's probably the gym we all
know it but guess what body boss can
help unlock your dream body with the
great 12 week body boss workout program
guess what my favorite part of this
whole thing is you do it at home in just
24 minutes a day three days a week
that's less than 90 minutes a week with
no equipment no subscription thanks to
the hashtag Boss effect or excess
post-exercise oxygen consumption you
burn fat long after your workout plus
with caring pro coaches and a free
Facebook group of supportive kick-ass
women you're never alone so try body
boss with this special offer just for
and get 25% off the fitness guide at
body boss comm / grace order now and get
free shipping and a money-back guarantee
this is the best deal ever guys get body
boss for 25 percent off at body boss
calm / grace 12 weeks from now you'll
thank yourself for starting now that's
body boss calm / grace okay we're back
with Lily Marsden okay one thing I want
to ask going down memory lane um I'm so
curious I think I've heard a little bit
about it in the videos that you and
Jocelyn just recently posted but I'd
love to know your first impressions of
meeting a couple different people at
clever so first of all what was your
first impression of meeting Joslin so I
started as an intern unpaid and I was
like commuting from Thousand Oaks every
day and also when I graduated from
college was when I felt like such bad
anxiety for the first time and it was
like unbearable which after I like even
kind of knew them a little bit literally
have to thank them so much because I
would go cry in their office cuz my like
palms would be sweating you have to type
code that Bella Thorne interview right
but I just remember going in for the
interview and being so nervous man I met
it was another girl that worked there
talk to y'all know that was the one
interviewing me but it was my friend
Dedra that I went to high school with
got me the interview uh-huh as if it was
like I'm super hard interviewing it
really you just need to know who to
email because it's not like we have like
thousands of applicants it was like two
people and we're here yeah but so she
gets me the interview I see her when I
go into the office give her a hug so
they're all interviewing me sees that I
give so she would early I sit down she
has okay we were hired let's take a tour
actually starts tomorrow
and then she introduces me and I had
like watched a bunch of the videos
before so I had seen Dana Jocelyn
because they were the faces of the
channel right but I don't remember
meaning Jocelyn as much as Dana cuz I
think I just talked to Dana more but
Jocelyn was just like very like bouncing
around but I always tell her the biggest
thing is they would film their
teleprompter stories and like now in the
studio if they have like a walk and talk
so they have to like be fully clothed
okay these [ __ ] all
but the work they'd have like these
really like you have like the peplum
like satin leather top Sodom like
statement necklaces and then workout
clothes and just like cashews and I'm
really how I shot every video cuz I'm
like hmm I get it yeah that makes sense
everything's a lie yeah but they were
like so nice oh and then joseline would
just like she burped my hump lips she's
human like no I didn't it was someone
else girl
but joseline would like give me notes of
stuff to do and she would verbally tell
me that she'd write them all down on
post and now and since she has literally
the worst hand I have really good
handwriting and I'm like okay do you
step up research do research on bella
thorne do research on this person and it
was just like and then I would do it but
it's like I'd graduated college I was
always I went to Arizona State so I feel
like it wouldn't seem this way but I was
always good at school well and it really
capable you know what you're a human and
you were smart and you can figure things
out I have my strong points like
research and like doing notes and making
them very like aesthetically pleasing
yes like that is I shouldn't if that was
a job like I should be something that
like writes not actually writes them but
like organizes textbooks okay and she
would give me these notes in her like
give me a research project and I'd bring
it back to her and be like here you go
this took me an hour but it's like
literally like anything you could
possibly need and she'd be like yes
before people would be like well they
were born this year like right in what
world are you going to need to know
their birth year yeah interview about
their movies they're just printing out
the Wikipedia papers three they played
all right but four inches tall who cares
so it was just like having the common
sense to like understand what kind of
questions they would ask anything yeah
but she was always just very grateful so
like I'm just happy oh well see that's
what I'm so we wanted to have Jocelyn
here today in this podcast but she's a
she's she's a busy independent lady now
and that's what I'm so excited about for
her is that I think Jocelyn he's an
amazing host and she knows how to like
turn on the facade of being a host and I
saw even in your very casual McMahon
video that she has a hard time turning
off the interviewers that I'm so excited
to get to know more about her without
her having to feel like she's a host of
something but she's also like that all
the time anyway right obviously like we
have a relationship where we're just
like I don't think we have to ask each
other stuff it's like when your nose
when you just like tell them a
conversation with each other yeah but
with her I feel like anytime you hang
out with her in someone new like
recently who I am obsessed with well so
flashback to VidCon this year we had
already been obsessed with her and I'd
show I'd found one of her videos and
then was like just the editing alone I
was like it's so good like old John
Hughes movie that's what her inspiration
yeah we asked her well Jocelyn asked her
a lot with any other questions
so we met her at VidCon finally I like
showed every single person the office is
like have you seen who Elmo says she's
gonna be huge like Casey nice that
starts shouting hurrah just like blowing
up and I'm like she's never gonna talk
to Twitter and then we met her at VidCon
but like Jocelyn met her first and
literally sent me a picture of them
together and I was like in one of the
SUVs like on my way back from a panel
like having a panic she got me tell Mel
sniped him and then I got you later in
the day oh my god it was so jealous
which also got sweet you and I'm like oh
my god literally fading out like there's
19 year old in a world yeah that's the
weird thing about VidCon is the only
time that you can like get too excited
about a teenager even more excited she
reached out to us like the less she came
out to LA this past month and she
reached out it was like hey girls we
haven't really had much of a chance to
like talk so I'd love to like grab
dinner or something
and literally I had screen shot and it
was about to send itself and my phone
starts ringing and Jocelyn faced having
me being like oh my god she's like so
cute just like so we're obsessed with
you you're heroes
what's your inspiration what do you want
to do in life limit plays wait a minute
how Dowson buzz never room podcast blows
my mind she does like the perfect
interview host when we actually filmed
the pilot of a podcast for clever a
while ago and like it was kind of maybe
gonna happen maybe not okay
Jed really wasn't much before about as
usual I was like yeah it was really good
we got a lot of good feedback for AB
like the higher-ups so I was like
literally it was just like you can put
me in Dawson in a room and be like here
are two topics talk and it's like six
hours later yes still there do you know
talk about the two things that they set
us out to talk about never know I'm so
excited I've already been like super fan
of like just a few videos that she's
already put out and so I'm like very
excited to see her be like less of house
Jocelyn and more of like maybe joseline
joseline even though it's like might not
be that different I'm excited for her
because I think she's gonna get to do
both yeah she like even today she
uploaded a video I was supposed to go
with her but I owe that Shay Mitchell
yeah like they're in a morgue
yeah and then so I was gonna vlog it and
it was gonna be like I brought up with
like that's been done or something and
then I had stayed up all night editing
or buck things and then was like I can't
go all good though okay she's gonna do
interviews and stuff - that's great and
she said the blog content great at that
I think that's gonna be a really
wonderful balance for her tonal okay
what was your first impression of Erin
when you met her I've tried to think of
this before and it's hard because Erin
started originally as the movies host
and oh okay not work on the movies
channel at all gotcha but Lisa and I who
I think you may be yes so who was like a
producer off-camera you guys tried to
wrangle on camera many times and she was
less agreeable than I think you are to
be on camera she just wasn't always down
for what we were doing I think she knew
the character she was playing in the
relationship of you guys that she was
playing like this straight girl of like
I don't want to do this and you guys I
wish I could say that was a character no
she's the sweetest and literally she's
like oh we're not friends but then she's
like here's Flores
Katy Perry very birthday are you so we
always shared it off as she left like a
year ago I think as pursue her own thing
but we always share an office like from
when I was an intern oh wow
back in our old Hollywood office we
shared one and it was like quote-unquote
an office but it was like I'm trying to
look in here for like size comparison
size of the kitchen so it's like the
counter so like a walk-in closet very it
was the closet where the server's were
okay so we would sit at our two desk
than we had a pillar in between us and
then there was this other desk next door
like the very loud servers so it didn't
feel super claustrophobic he threw to
see and then whenever we had a new
person come in audition they would like
a new freelance or something they come
and they'd write their script in the
office at the table behind us so me and
Lisa were always like oh gee and now
it's so funny because so many people I
know like like Tracy stuff people I'm
like oh that's funny like I was just
saying they're doing like my bella
thorne research so I kinda remember
coming in and then I do know that she
almost like the style channel did exist
a rich so Erin came in and was like
writing her scripts near you yeah okay
so but like we didn't really talk like
Lisa's not friendly anywhere in the
night I don't even know like then she
was auditioning just in general for a
hosting position but it used to be very
much like per channel okay so at first I
think it was for movies and then our
style host was leaving okay yeah because
she was like no one watches this I'm
sick of killing myself
so then what she was kind of almost
grooming her and to take over clever
style gosh and I don't think Erin really
wanted to because clever salt was stupid
and didn't it literally would be like a
thousand views a video and it was like
like fashion news like red carpet outfit
about the designers and like knowing our
new tube really cares about that so then
I don't remember when it like the
decision got made but it was like okay
clever style is dead and until then
beauty break revived it later like years
late
yeah but and then Aaron took over clever
movies oh and she said then she and she
like didn't know a lot about movies in
the beginning yeah she a movie person
I'm someone that someone mentions Marvel
and I'm like I can't even like it makes
my brain hurt even trying to understand
how things connected and how there's
like universes and how the different
companies no idea why are there so many
spider-man's
I just don't understand yeah exactly the
same she like learned all of that and
like it's like an expert now that's
impressive in itself yeah a lot of weird
jobs so I feel like she's used to like
really I think to like step up like just
kind of throw herself into it but like
it's a lot to memorize and she genuinely
became like the Klepper of movies like
resident expert oh that's cool okay what
was your first impression of Jarrett
sleeper it's a favorite here on not too
deep and I'm always like it's so funny
you ask that because no one ever has
well I'm so I feel like I kind of want
to start like it's not what you would
expect oh I can't wait I kinda want to
start this like sub podcast that's just
asking people that Jarrett has met what
their first impressions are I met Jeremy
perfection yeah when we were working on
my music with the fine brothers like
years and years and years ago that's
when we first met each other I never
seen that but I do remember when he
started all the comments were like
that's metal from my music yeah and so
we met there and he was like pursuing
you know traditional acting and so it's
like me and like jacksFilms and a couple
other like youtubers but then intermixed
with the like real actors so I was like
a weird hodgepodge really fun that's
where Mitchell and Jared I like first
all met each other oh my girl was this
this was 2011 2010 like eight years ago
seven years ago cuz Mitchell played they
brought him on as a character that was
Punk I think he played Punk and Jaret
played metal and then Jared I just think
yeah I was Idol I was a pop music yeah
yeah yeah and then Jaret was metal and
then I think he probably it's the fine
brothers made it it's somewhere on there
but I'm doing tonight but then Jared
like we were still friends but he wasn't
really in the YouTube space but then the
next thing I knew he was like doing
something clever still he's like weirdly
not and I don't I've always I sometimes
I've ever really talked to him that
specifically about but it's weird to me
that he doesn't have his own channel
because I feel like he's knows he can't
commit to it I think he I think yes yeah
he's got too many ideas his podcast my
good bad brain is like really fantastic
how long was the episode you filled with
a I kept looking at my phone I mean like
how many subtle things can like context
clues can I give this person before I go
how long are we gonna be recording for
but that said Jared sleeper has a really
amazing podcast called Brad my good bad
brain that's all about like his thoughts
on like mental health and he has a lot
of really in-depth conversations really
in-depth conversations it's the opposite
of this because you're filming it you
forget because who knows like there's no
cameras so it's like it's like you're on
his couch he gives you a microphone you
sink into his couch
we're like four hours this is so funny
though because when he got brought on it
was him and Tracey got brought on to
host a new show totally clever and this
is when they literally just a few months
earlier had like canceled all
programming on clever TV and taken to
Dana Drazen off and we're like hey um
you're gonna go clever news now we don't
need you anymore over here even though
that was the channel that they grew from
the ground up big kids land they gave
and then Kingsley came in and he had a
show he had like king of drama King
drama King yo that was the only show on
ClevverTV for a bit even though that was
like our biggest channel they like just
wiped it clean they were like we're
gonna start over and make it something
different
Wow gave him the show and then they
started totally clever right after which
has had so many different identities
I remember just seeing randomly like on
some social media platform
Jarett and Tracy just like on the street
in Venice like so a man on the street
interviews and I was like what is this
but that's funny cuz that's how it ended
that like really gets to me cuz like it
was them being like Tracy Jarrett yeah
like people didn't always it didn't do
that well because their humor is like
too smart for a lot of people like it's
smart and dry it was too over everyone's
had it
maybe sad that it didn't catch on
because there isn't yeah cuz they're so
in on the joke with each other that it
makes other people uncomfortable
thinking that they're like fighting or
said what I was like yeah confusing but
before that it was like kind of I almost
feel like you probably did you come in
for you came in for drama King I came in
for drama King dude I'm in for like some
like award show weird I came in for news
I was in I came in for something I feel
like it was with Aaron and someone else
I remember coming in and begin a hot
little box to do and it was like I
forget exactly what maybe for my first
book or something I was like yeah and
then I came in it was like two girls thr
it might have an errand and joseline
should be fair and I remember not
putting that together until I came back
to do Kingsley saying and I was like oh
this is the same place that I was in
before and then when I went down the
wormhole of discovering beauty break a
couple years ago and all that stuff I
was like wait a minute it's all like the
fog is lifting this comes into play
usually I can track it by like what
color my hair was not to be so Tyler
Oakley 2014 I'm like what my hair was
that they started Jerry and Tracy I
don't think we're working oh no you were
saying you had gone down a wormhole and
found clever style yeah you'd shout at
us out in a video and I think it was
like maybe we met at VidCon yeah I am
I started getting tweets that was like
oh my god grace just called you guys hot
grace blood luck and I'm like out like a
bachelorette party in Denver and it was
so so drugged and I literally like look
at my honesty what I'm like at a bar I
don't like try to listen to what you say
I think you just are like I got obsessed
with you guys a hundred layer challenge
oh yeah viewing peoples are something
you like the clever girls did it really
cool I got obsessed I went down a full
wormhole in one of my states of like
depression where I go I don't need to
get on my bed for a couple weeks I have
to because I just like understand yeah I
found you guys that's how I found the
try guys - yeah
found um sugar pine seven like it so I
find all the greatest hits oh and I'm
really sad and I don't don't want to
leave my house for any reason and then I
go download the content yep
oh my god we're here now I look back at
it I like some episodes I think you're
hilarious not other ones I'm like I
thought this was so funny well that was
so great because mamrie and I forever
have been trying to figure out like a
simple concept that was easy to produce
that wasn't scripted that felt like us
being genuinely around each other like
that sort of thing and you guys were
doing it I was like this is perfect I
love this I relate to these people
they're not putting on like friends like
you that's why you'll get by it
literally is just us trying products
right but we just don't have a three
camera setup I say this in front of two
cameras right now even know what I'm
filming myself a lot and do a lot of
like punching well that's what I used to
do it now I was like no I always said
that I was annoyed with the whole back
to Glover and me not making any money
that I'm like I could have made this
show in my living room no we're watching
it because it has three cameras no it's
just like yeah this the tone of it was
just very relatable and very cool and I
didn't feel high production but it also
didn't feel like you're shooting on an
iPhone like it just felt like oh this is
very digestible so what was your first
impression of Jared it was so funny
because he started at this like they
wanted him more polished and because
that Klepper TV was very like young like
really Justin Bieber and Selena so it
was like very like they made air be not
what chair it is and also he has so many
different like he's very much in
chameleon I feel like that he's a mood
ring he is a different color every day
he's all bad like Sundays you'll come in
looking like a lumberjack and then other
times he's like in a row but and I'm
like no oh my music he literally come in
and be like totally depressed then come
in one day would be like where's Jared
they're like he's studying law in the
corner of the green room right now my
first impression the weirdest because
now I would never in a million years
ever say this literally was just he was
like frat boy oh oh yeah oh just for a
point
not like him that's not even know but
I've told him that and now I like loving
so much but it was like so just like him
kind of like someone was giving them
like kind of like loose general
guidelines and then he was playing into
it I think it was like just a job for
him yeah I was like being kind of an
[ __ ] and just like I don't know but
it's so funny because I remember really
not liking him I think I also was like
bitter that they had like canceled
everything on coverage and everyone that
works there yeah no I don't plan to that
for sure then it was just kind of like
why and then now I'm like oh my god
literally they're two of the funniest
people I've ever met oh that was my
first impression I think jurors were in
like a black tank top and he drove away
on a motorcycle is like this piece of
[ __ ] I don't even remember when I
started being like because he always
used to come in and talk to us too and
he was very like Kathy hello I don't
think it took long for us to be like oh
wow
yeah I like I just easy in a corner I'd
never met anyone like him he's the
coolest person he is a goof troop in one
character okay we're gonna take one more
quick break and when we get back we have
a bazillion Twitter questions for you
Lily if you don't mind answering them
sure you've heard of the Internet we'll
be right back with more Larson uh not
too deep you know Jack for many of us
the day does not start until we get that
morning energy boost you know what I'm
talking about I think you're talking
about coffee yeah yeah now there is a
new way to enjoy your daily cup of joe
thanks to Cafe monster available in
vanilla mocha and salted caramel cafe
Monster is shaking up the ready to drink
coffee category with indulgent gourmet
coffee that's only 190 calories and not
to mention with a hundred and fifty
milligrams of caffeine from coffee beans
B vitamins and coffee fruit extract cafe
monster offers a simplified energy blend
that contains a third at less sugar than
the leading national brand in fact it's
one hundred fewer calories per bottle in
the competition but you'd never know
that by tasting it instead you get all
the same feel and flavor as your local
we house and you don't have to wait in
line you don't have to interact with
other humans and they've got three great
flavours as vanilla there's mocha salted
caramel Oh fantastic mocha is my
personal favorites it does taste like
chocolate milk I could be a vanilla girl
on certain days but they're all I mean
they're to me it's just delicious isn't
it give it give it a shot try it out
cafe monster chill it down shake it up
enjoy this episode of now to diapers
brought to you by Green Chef they are a
USDA certified organic company that
includes everything you need to easily
cook delicious meals that you can feel
good about green chef recipes are quick
and easy with step-by-step instructions
chef tips and photos to guide you along
the way they send a wide variety of
organic ingredients and imaginative new
recipes each week delivered right to
your door with green chef it's easy to
maintain a specialty diet and enjoy
exciting new options there Pro meal
plans include paleo vegan vegetarian
keto gluten-free omnivore and carnivore
green chef's expert chefs design recipes
with thoughtfully sourced ingredients
and gourmet flavor that you typically
only find in restaurants green chef
thinks dinners should be planned around
your life and not the other way around
so let green chef do the meal planning
shopping and prep for you week after
week switch up your meal plan and change
the box you're getting whenever you want
I as you guys know love subscription box
services for cooking because it cuts
down on waste and green chef is amazing
because like they said they have so many
specialty diet plans which is fantastic
whether you're a carnivore whether
you're a vegan they have you covered
plus helps you venture out of your
normal cooking comfort zone and even if
you don't even have a comfort zone
cooking because you don't do it they get
you started and for $50 off your first
box you guys can go to green chef dot us
slash grace that's green chef us slash
grace okay we're back okay Lilly you've
answered these two questions that's
happy well I'm gonna get to the two
questions I asked every single guests on
the podcast because you've been on the
podcast before you've answered these
before but maybe the
okay so the first question is who alive
or dead would you most want to throw
cold spaghetti act can I like make like
a metaphorical person yes justify yeah
you can say a corporation for Charles I
was gonna say if we didn't answer
yeah spideyman
yes spiderweb of cold spaghetti could it
be something a little worse than that
could there be like some sauce in there
as well yeah yeah who knows what kind of
like food allergies they have that's
true or though if they have a gluten
issue or something okay
the other question but ask every single
guest is to tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story but you can only use
three words or small phrases or some
sort of like hybrid - college jogging
front lawn I cuz I even feel like the
last time I answered it was like kind of
like a what you made never actually it
didn't actually happen it was like an
almost scenario that's what you can do
it close I think it was literally the
three words last time we're almost
earlier today like that is that you're
mine everyday though late night I'm
gonna consider late night one word even
though I late-night expired SpaghettiOs
oh no I'm not SpaghettiOs last forever
it was like apocalypse foods other
stories mostly I don't know how much
dancing there was but it was them who so
much throwing out that I and I've al
coholic jeez like I've throw up yeah
this was not this is difference
oh man I love I try to like suck it up
and go do a shoot Pro chef Jack twitch
is a fitness show
oh yeah that was Jarrett's and Aaron was
driving us there it was like 8:00 a.m.
on the way up and then I couldn't do it
I stayed in her car for the whole hour
shoot threw up salt like I just kept
getting out throwing up and then she do
it all by herself because of spaghetti
oh yeah all right well you know we're
all striving in our own way I don't even
like
it was just that I was like really
hungry what I got yeah I get it I didn't
have anything my kitchen but it was bad
pretty sure that I have like Joey break
in case of emergen not spaghetti oh okay
let's get into these Twitter questions
we got an immediate response from Joslin
Davies
she asked would she like to have pudding
or ham she's only asking this because
someone asked what's the pudding thing
pudding I love put it you love pudding
it's like never something I really
vocalize and then we did a cheat day
about pudding it was like I was just
losing Magnolia Bakery
banana pudding never why do you mean I
don't think about pudding out all the
time but then that was wild like it had
never really come up and then we do this
episode and it was like I got so talked
about another type throw you up because
I ate too well I think pudding as little
off-putting to me because it has an
identity crisis it's not solid and it's
not soup it's in between salad and soup
and that makes me confuse what world is
salad involves you know solid I don't
know it just tastes like I don't like
anything so it is weird that I would
like something with a semi strange
texture and like I also love like flan
oh no your texture okay but yeah that
literally was that question someone put
in a Q&A that we did like four years ago
and we like Reddit and I like you're
taking away my hands or like I just
can't use that like what are they
mystics involved your hands get taken
away I gonna eat that part you can't put
it through a straw that's why it's
confusing
you can put super-strong yeah no this is
gross that makes soup gross
most soup noodles they feel like wooden
butt
have you have tomato soup cream-based
soup than maybe well that's just tomato
soup through astrologist a Bloody Mary
at the end of the day very theoretical
if Jarrett was here we would have two
more hours of conversation about the
origin of soup okay someone to know
what's the worst emoji ever created is
the one that you hate but I feel like
there's a lot that I'm like why does
that exist but like you won't give me if
you what's the worst okay let me expand
this a little bit what's the worst emoji
response that you could get or like
let's even go emoji list like the worst
text response I mean the go-to is K all
right that that was immediately yeah
like this KK it's fine my mom doesn't
understand text advocate so like I'll
always think she's mad but like she just
doesn't get it
oh no my mom lol meant lots of love for
like two years so she'd be like grandmom
fell in the shower
lol mom like you know I mean laughing
out loud she's like no idea but then my
dad I don't know where he developed this
my dad ends every text with an ellipses
so it's the most for like foreboding
thing ever do a lot too but it's always
like in but she won't do it for ones
that it actually would make sense for
its ones but it's like so are you mad
like what's like yeah actually I guess
that's okay I don't do it my dad will do
it for like a hundred having a great day
dot dot dot will it be but what does she
really want me to do today no I just do
you think there's so many random food
emojis though that shouldn't exist
yeah is there one that doesn't exist
wait do you know I hope that you're not
one of these people because I definitely
use it all the time and I always feel
very personally attacked but people like
don't like the crying face emoji like
the laugh cry whoa laughs crying um I
think I'm not I don't feel either way
about it I use it like it's definitely
my most use
okay three crying emojis is like how I
respond to something that I think it's
funny I think that's totally I
appreciate a crying face emoji more than
lmao oh I don't do that because I've
never laughed in my house I've always
been a haha girl I'll do like three ha
oh my god
yeah 3 husband it's really funny I have
a friend in college that was like trying
to like talk to this guy and he said it
autocorrected to like a lot I mean
indirectly that's a great way to shut
down a text conversation with someone
that you don't want to be having it with
just I I mean I kind of I'm gonna use
that down in the back pocket when I talk
to someone that I don't want to continue
a conversation with but I'm too [ __ ] to
like cut it down so what do you think he
interpreted as speaking of that someone
to know what is she looking for in a
dude I'm interested in what her type is
tbh well if you asked Jocelyn she always
goes wow he oh and she describes your
type match as well he's probably an
athlete preferably football but like you
hit the quarterback because he had to be
smart too maybe wide receiver and then
he got injured and then he had to get
into business or maybe he still works in
the sports field but it's doing
something else and like literally will
go into this very very hyper specific
situation I feel like I don't always end
up liking what my type is sure but like
my type I would say is very like like
frat boy jock really but I think in
recent years I've transitioned more like
I like a good beard but I think visually
I don't really want to make out with a
beard it just kind of hurts seems at jmu
um yeah but I think no I think just
someone that doesn't annoy the [ __ ] out
of me is pretty much a that's a great
way
which I have not found yet I mean in Los
Angeles it's just so easy to date you a
few times I find it I'm like oh my god I
don't hate them it's like oh I'm not
looking for a relationship or oh okay oh
they're in a relationship I'll be like
talking to summon it like oh this is
great it's like I have a girlfriend like
what do you mean what do you I wouldn't
why would I be talking to you right now
it's never the nice initiating things
with guys are the girlfriends it's
always the opposite who's this and I'm
like I'm not gonna look him up on
Facebook I won't be creepy and then like
when I do I'm like maybe I should have
because that I would have solved that
they're married no okay not really
social media is fun that you should but
kind of not
okay so I want to know if you had a
children's book written about you what
would it say if you had a child if you
had a children's book written about you
what would it be called and some and
they said no follow-up question of
course normal children I think it's a
great title I would by that I mean like
I like can't even remember any what I
used to bond pop yeah yeah it's like
those are so specific to what but it is
like at my side a storyline those are
just dr. Seuss I feel looks like the
crafty worm I don't know Marcelle the
show yeah my saw the cell show a show it
was a video that they turned into a
children's book oh but it's always like
an anthropomorphize like yeah okay um
your favorite Katy Perry album are you
still a huge Katy Perry son walked into
my apartment me oh there anything else
so you really like Katy Perry I was like
I feel like it I don't realize that I do
have a lot of stuff but it's more that I
just like there's Katy Perry things that
I've acquired over the years when I was
a big fan and then there's other things
that I acquired that I didn't care about
so like if I move like I throw away and
I like don't have that many things that
are like out on display right a few
things I'm like oh I guess that does
look weird I wouldn't say I'm like
literally like in college
it was like oh my god I'm obsessed with
her yeah this is amazing now it's like I
love her music it's all great yeah
you're more like an adult now and yeah
so I would hope that I'm not just
totally obsessed but it's funny that I
did I then after all those years of
being obsessed with her I met her twice
last year Wow I was like I know so
finally did she remember you the second
time no no no no I get that but she told
me I was funny I was like so this means
I'm a comedian
no that's your Teenage Dream handsome
okay yeah that's a good one
when did your Dr Pepper addiction start
I actually don't know and is it still a
real thing yeah I cut back a lot I I
literally was drinking probably six a
day because wait they have them in the
refrigerator at work all the time so I
would just be like stressed and be like
I need to get up and like go like do
something it's like going to get a drink
it's like a nice like going away from
your desk kind of situation yeah I
totally get it I feel like just when I'm
anxious all just like so
and it just tastes good so yeah then I
was drinking like thousands of calories
I probably drink like two ish two or
three maybe that's good now and then I'm
in high school that like literally every
day before high school I would go to
McDonald's for actually I believe they'd
mr. Pibb at the time oh they changed at
one point um so I I definitely know
where is Jocelyn Johnson is all the
other ratios I called you because I'm on
my way home and I didn't think I would
be able to talk to you tomorrow and I
just miss you and I haven't time I know
is there separation anxiety no
absolutely because you guys I'm assure
you it's in it's impossible to
anticipate what it's like when you're
not seeing each other every single day
for eight hours I look back to like back
to the original question but you asked
me the very beginning it was like what
was it hard to make that kind of plunge
yeah it was never about the YouTube
channel and like I was like okay if I'm
a flop that'll suck but like my backup
plan was like I'll just edit for be sure
like that was a very and I had people
already lined up that I'd reached out it
was like
hey do you need any help because yeah I
was gonna reach out to you and be like I
saw you two years ago that was like I'm
figuring my [ __ ] out maybe I feel like
people that watch us even know that I
edit but a lot of like the youtuber like
just people I know in real life don't
necessarily because like they don't
assume you work for a corporation and so
the corporation has editors or whatever
I didn't know that you had the lil um
the lilz lens your Instagram yeah that's
just genuine beautiful photography can
you do what camera do you use the way I
got an ad D for myself for Christmas
last year okay
it took I've been like kind of like
prepping for the apocalypse but I was
like okay well let me buy things why do
you have some kind of money shirt if I'm
totally screwed at least I have
everything I need and like not be able
to film a video if I had to yeah but um
yeah and I bought it and then I I've
always liked photography but like I
don't really know anything about cameras
people like oh what was your I don't
[ __ ] know it's great but I [ __ ]
love Photoshop so I'll use automatic
settings yeah I'll take mediocre
pictures but if you could take a
mediocre picture you can always make it
better like I just like editing a lot so
it is just a nice hybrid and I plan on
doing my goal was to do one picture
every day that didn't happen well it's
what's up there right now is beautiful
and I had no idea until Diane did a
bunch of like quick research for this
episode and like put that in there
nothing wait a minute what area yeah
from Korea yeah I was like wait a minute
I looked it up this morning I was like
holy [ __ ] I yea existed honestly my goal
was like cuz I I've always like
literally I'm the go-to like I make
people's I've made joslyn's sister's
birthday like her kids birthday
invitations for the last few years like
the shop has always been like just my
side like yeah one of back when I was
like even just like an Associate
Producer and nothing was like I didn't
have any real responsibilities one of
the like evergreen things I did for
clever it was it was originally gonna be
like if celebrities didn't have hair and
I was photoshopping made me bald but
then we didn't want people to get
offended
and think it was like any kind of cancer
could we do so that I made villains just
so I can have like oh and also it was
kind of when I realized that I wasn't
getting my channel back so I was like
well I guess I'll find another creative
outlet it was also like maybe I could
get some side income for that because
like a lot of brands will ask you to
post like product shots right and I'm
like that's not gonna do well I need to
be in it right but if it's my
photography Instagram I don't like I'm
not in any of them because I'm not
self-timer in the pictures so like could
be a good alternative and it's just fun
to have something to like it's super
cool I highly recommend people check it
out if they're like me and had no
[ __ ] clue that this other Instagram
existed well we have reached the end of
the podcast but before you leave we're
gonna give you the gift that we give
every guest that makes time for us is a
personalized fortune cookie just for you
that you are more than welcome to open
up and read hopefully into the
microphone on camera later in your car
and like send it to us I forget what our
fortune was if you want dry mouth just
try these I don't eat the fortune
cookies I didn't advise it Jack was the
ones that it was okay
spoiled it like a pill my fortune is a
Coors Light brand deal where you
actually get to keep the money you make
is a near near future no my near and
dear future comma Lily Marston
oh I mean wait it's the university
Victor yet I've gotten a few care
packages it actually fun fact they
invited me
from Coors Light yeah they and they sent
me a note that even called them course
lattes which I really appreciated
no they invited me to do something and
was - they invited me something this
year and I couldn't go it was like some
retreat that they partnered with someone
sure I know it was super cool it was
really sad two years ago they reached
out they were like we have this summit
we're doing where you go hiking through
the Rockies I was like I think you have
very much misunderstood my brain it was
literally like a mountain climbing trip
and I was like I understand the parallel
but no I understand but they recently
sent me a custom snowboarding jacket
that word I don't I don't know on that
note where can people find your channel
it's quote new but it's been there
you'll find you it's caught the Lil's
channel but I think if you just search
my name it'll come up it's like Bell
anyone and then Lily underscore Marcin
on Twitter and Instagram awesome if you
guys haven't already please go check out
Lily but support this new independent
contractor and creator also not to
interrupt you but soon based on one of
the tweets we got I think that we are
going to be filming a Bob Ross tutorial
yes I really want to do this honestly I
think it might happen before this
episode comes out so you should check it
might be up it might be up thank you
again Lily for making time joslyn's
we'll see you when we see to deep deep
deep deep Cathy Monster is shaking up
they're ready to drink coffee category
with indulgent gourmet coffee that's
only 190 calories available in vanilla
mocha and salted caramel with a hundred
fifty milligrams of caffeine from coffee
beans B vitamins and coffee fruit
extract in every bottle caffeine monster
offers a simplified energy blend that
contains a third less sugar than the
leading national brand but you still get
all the feel and flavor of your local
coffee house and I have tried the mocha
it is delicious
you have to try it it tastes so good
cafe monster chill it down shake it up
enjoy not too deep as a production of
grace helbig incorporated a producer and
directed by Jack ferry producer and
editor melissa demons writing by diane
king production assistants by Katrina
Hannah
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]